here's here's something speaking of
AEIOU school and all that i was howling
and I mean actually howling at this clip
of this dude in blackface teaching like
a science class or some [ __ ] he's
dressed up like common and he's he's
mimicking his like Intel AI commercial
but he just ends up looking like Robert
Downey jr. from Tropic Thunder
he's like fully like like black face to
the neck like and is he bald he's bald
okay
yeah or maybe that could've been a bald
cap I don't know the lighting in that
clip is awful
but I couldn't watch it I opened it up
and I was so couldn't I started like
started and I was too awkward I couldn't
watch it because everyone in the class
knows that it's [ __ ] up but he somehow
thinks said it's okay
I was howling just thinking so many
things I'm like first of what was going
through his mind when he was wiping the
makeup off no no okay he was over all
right that first thought was he just
feel like no dude what about what he was
thinking when it was halfway on do you
think we got past his eyes and he was
like yeah this is still so sick there's
just so many steps that should have
inspired her to like think that one bro
first of all he's teaching like high
school so you know classes start like
seven did he put it on before work so is
he in like blackface at 6:00 in the
morning eating breakfast his wife like
driving through traffic in blackface
just like looking at people like was a
and no one lasting comment yeah getting
into character and no one's like yo what
that's not cool it's 4:00 a.m. just to
get up extra early to put it on me honey
sorry I'm it's four I have to get into
costume she wasn't like maybe don't
maybe just don't
was was it at like a Halloween thing or
was it I think it was I was teaching
like a lesson yeah it was like he's like
I think he was trying to talk about like
AI but like when you hear him like he
doesn't sound like comment at all like
doesn't want to bring it up most play a
sound
he sounds bro oh my [ __ ] god dude I
got to hear this
I was crying laughing like nobody like
if you got up at 4:00 and at 4:30 after
you stepped out of the shower you're
like it's time [ __ ] or do you put it
on his desk people are trying to go hey
Mike whoa what the [ __ ]
so I am I'm getting ready for today's
lesson what's up hey Mike what's up god
what are you doing dude what I'm just
he's halfway it's just here thinking
about it Spira CLE like this split
completely looka to talk basketball TAS
head is just laughs was blackface what's
up dude dude he [ __ ] he only has the
front and the neck the back and the top
of the head is not done because he can't
see back there so the banks just white
and then he turns around and then it's
just like what's up oh hey Mike
yo what's good oh hey thank God that
you're here could you do the top of my
head no no no black top of your head you
[ __ ] [ __ ] are you asking me there's
like so many points where people could
have been like this is [ __ ] up that's
what I'm saying do that that's what had
me crying I was a teacher how do you not
know that that's not okay dude listen
him he sounds like Robert Downey jr. but
in Tropic Thunder but not doing a good
job
let's see with my man dude I think he
realizes right at the end he's like this
person is filming him he's like because
he goes like going to and not like a
second person he's like wait and then it
ends yeah you like he like he like gets
the hands are like he's ready to go
again
millions of people Justin Trudeau had a
damn photo that's bad that's so bad so
many levels to that he could have
stopped there's just so many hours
before that happen you know what I'm
saying yeah you think he probably knows
why Evan was like babe I got a really
nice um good plan for tomorrow's class
imma kill this you kill this [ __ ] you're
gonna [ __ ] love him do and then as
he's explaining it there's like five
things where she's like and so if you're
gonna rap to what in blackface
no all of those none of it is good none
of that stuff's okay do they have the
the half-submerged blackface is is
hilarious just quarter head like the
front and the top of the he can't see
but not the back and not the bottom it's
just like 1/4 of the pie and just just
to the eyelids that's so good
[ __ ] hell dude I was so good you know
our boys back home were just like crying
just say with the was he like wiping off
the makeup feeling like you know like he
killed it that or like did he feel like
you know when girls put on their makeup
to go meet a dude and they catch it with
another girl like they just go home and
he's like I'm a [ __ ] I can't believe I
did that to myself I'm a hole for him I
can't believe it I did that oh we are we
are in State College Pennsylvania right
now and Penn State I've never been here
what's up Penn State literally the only
thing I know about Penn State is lest
that coach dusky yeah better fog yeah
literally the only thing I know yeah
well don't say that on stage tonight
okay yeah the only thing I know is y'all
had a pedophile you'll probably get to
probably be pretty awkward yeah I'm sure
there's a point in the show where I
could use that name and oh yeah there is
I guess you could ride out and see take
a risk yeah this that's what counties
about man practically taking risks dude
you're not taking R is if you're not
name dropping pedophiles regularly in
your set about doing commonplace you're
not doing common blackface and rapping
about AI you're not taking risks to
truly take him that's what he was doing
exactly like what I want to push the
boundaries of Education with yeah and
common what can you do with technology
it's up to you Tropic Thunder
just getting the lines down and [ __ ] you
don't even know you all you know you are
yes I do
i'ma do disguises to do plane another do
do do you damned Robert you nailed that
one
[ __ ] it
[Music]